Hello there. Is there something I can help you with?
Yes, I was wondering if it would be possible to reserve a classroom.
You need to use a classroom? Is this for personal use?
No, it's for my club. I'm the president of "Friends of the Disabled"...
...and we were hoping to use a room for our next meeting.
I see. You need to ask the professor for permission, then it shouldn't be a problem.
Okay, sounds great. Do you happen to know how big the room is?
It's a regular lecture hall, so I imagine it has about 50 to 60 desks in it.
That will be plenty big enough for us. Thank you very much for your help.
No trouble at all. Feel free to see me when you have questions.